hey guys it is Tuesday I'm your friendly
neighborhood news Rita I hope you're
having a good day and here's what's been
going on my goodness is it a good day to
be a big fan of old games as 9 classic
titles have been re-released he is that
you got to choose from my very favorite
to lucasarts adventure game full
throttle is coming out in all its
remastered glory today but it's been
very good company as voodoo vince
remastered Wonder Boy the Dragons trap
and Disney afternoon collection have
also arrived alongside it Disney
afternoon collection consists of six
different games Chip and Dale Rescue
Rangers and its sequel darkwing duck
duck tales and its sequel and tailspin I
know it's like the best Russian nesting
doll ever just because they all came out
on the same day though doesn't mean
you're getting the same sort of remaster
as pointed out by the head of the video
game history foundation Frank Capaldi
Disney have preserved the original look
while wonder boy and full throttle have
new artwork that you can switch up for
the old-school graphics as you like full
throttle and voodoo Vince remastered
will run you 15 bucks while the Disney
afternoon collection and Wonder Boy are
just a little pricier at twenty bucks
Dark Souls publisher Bandai Namco has
revealed it's a new game an RPG where
you play as a vampire yeah alright take
my money if you like me aren't sick of
vampires yet you'll be happy to hear
that the new game is set to be a dungeon
exploration type hard action RPG the
game is in development by the same team
responsible for the God Eater series and
if you need a better idea of what you're
in for you can check out the full
stylish teaser trailer on gamespot code
vein is set in a post-apocalyptic near
future where you assume the role of a
super-powered vamp called a revenant
revenants have lost most of their
memories and live as part of a society
called vain you'll need to consume blood
to avoid turning into a lost I don't
know what that is but it sounds bad you
can also bring along an AI controls
companion as you explore for mitsui is
reporting that the game is only about
thirty percent done and is unlikely to
arrive before 2018 but there's something
to look forward to
yet to announce platforms but more info
is due on april 20 finally respawn have
revealed titanfall tues next expansion
called a glitch in frontier to out on
April 25 the free DLC will include two
maps a faction another game mode and
plenty more goodies the first new map
called glitch is described as
medium-sized and is inspired by Captain
lastimosa from Planet of Harmony the new
deck arena is specifically for the
live-fire game mode which was introduced
as part of last month's free update
you'll be able to join the new mr the n
faction that could be connected to the
in-game marvin automated assistance you
know those unarmed helper robots that
just sort of walk around really
dangerous places finally the Titans will
one mode marked for death has arrived in
titanfall 2 marked for death sees one
player on each team marked as targets
and it's up to both teams to try and
kill the opposing team's target while
defending their own respawn have also
outlined all the contents coming to
titanfall 2 over the next three months
including new maps in you tighten and a
steady stream of cosmetic items and game
updates that is everything I've got for
you today do let me know down in that
comment section what you cared about and
I will see you again same time tomorrow